estamos viendo tal vez el inicio de una
nueva campaña a la presidencia por parte
del trump y de ser así sigue gozando de
la misma aceptación que tuvo en 2016
bueno no podrías tener exactamente la
misma porque no tiene el acceso a las
redes sociales a los medios de
comunicación como lo estuvo en ese
entonces en el año 2016 sin embargo si
existe una población un segmento de la
población que realmente lo apoya que
piensa que hubo fraude en las elecciones
y que no se encuentran
satisfechos con los resultados a nivel
económico claro precisamente por la
pandemia la inflación el manejo de la
economía que es muy difícil por las
cuestiones
económicas por por la pandemia en ti
pero sí tiene una gran aceptación y
todavía un público muy nutrido podría
incrementar su apoyo pero recordemos que
el prsc expresidente trump no tiene los
medios de comunicación y las redes
sociales a favor o las tenía hace
algunos y ahora que tanta influencia
sigue teniendo sobre el partido
republicano de cara a las elecciones de
medio término
es difícil es difícil poder entender
esto porque está dentro del partido
republicano hay un segmento que quisiera
tener un personaje tan fuerte como él
pero por el otro está todo en esta tele
excelente intermedia entre los
candidatos van a separarse un poco como
fue el año pasado en realidad esto les
podría ayudar a tener a tener más
adeptos pero en realidad que ellos
quieren es una figura fuerte como trump
es difícil poder medir dentro del
partido republicano hoy por hoy que
tanta aceptación tiene o no de
presidente pero si lo que requieren los
republicanos es una figura fuerte no
sabemos dice a trump u otra persona pero
si hay mucho descontento en una parte de
la sociedad estadounidense muy
importante entonces se quiere un
liderazgo se quiere cambiar con el
actual régimen y se quiere volver al
partido republicano